what is your emergency hi i want to
report like a drunk driver or something
what street are you on
um a car hold on a second
[Applause]
hi
cali ascendant lake forest california
926 real estate why not
guy just nailed three cars
and he's trying to leave okay what color
type of car is he in
it looks like a black truck i don't know
what kind it is
huh
just two-door yeah okay
yeah
all right come on okay all right and
then you know i found it in the car
you know if anyone was in the car so i
can't see his license plate he's not
going to where the car won't go nowhere
okay so you can't see anything he's
struck
you there yeah you can't see the plane
no no i'm not going up there not unless
i got my gun is he being violent or
aggressive no but he's either drunk or
messed up why do you think that
because he ain't getting out of the car
and the car is
movable
he sounded drunk too
i don't i don't know two with four sixty
four sam sixty frenzo and i know one
kai
vincent dad
in any one hotel one
a black pickup
hit three parked vehicles county fires
in route
460 units coffee
from city hall
462 temperature
too dark for
the informant to get a place the
informant states the subject is 390
because the male driver locked the door
when the informant went up to the
vehicle unknown if he's injured
[Music]
four six 464-1033 subjects armed with a
knife refusing to come out stage 91
hey watch out bro bro bro bro come over
here come over here
get out of the way
hey man you're all right
hey dude it's okay it's not the end of
the world we don't need you're okay
hey go inside get out of the house
there's a guy with a gun get away get in
the fucking house we got our guns out go
away
hey man
world hey it's all right you're okay
it's gonna be a male white it's okay man
you're not in trouble sir get away we
have our guns pointed we could shoot you
move away
hey man it's okay don't worry about it
hey man you're not in trouble it's not
the end of the world dude just put the
knife down okay
it's not a big deal man don't worry
about it
okay you're all right
hey
it's not the end of the world dude just
put the knife down and we can uh we can
we can sort this out all right
462 getting yeah
just keep talking to him bro keep
talking hey man it's okay i'm deputy
what can i do to get you to comply 464
subject's still uncooperative inside his
vehicle
what can i get you to comply man you're
doing all right it's okay
don't worry about it you're not in
trouble
it's just a car accident it's an
accident you're not in trouble
we don't want to hurt you can you please
put the knife down
put the knife down please sir what can i
get you to do to comply
we don't want to hurt you
what can i do to help you
tell him we could take him to like a
mental hospital or anything like that
hey man we can get you uh we can take
you to a hospital
okay do you have friends that you can
talk to
we don't want to hurt you dude
hey um what's up
i'm thinking when we push back dude
yeah but if he starts stabbing himself
we won't know dude because he's facing
the knife to him
if he starts tying himself we gotta do
something yeah but i mean no we don't
we don't have to do something if he
starts having himself
we don't want to hurt you man i don't
want to get too far where he books it
dude and runs yeah okay
yeah
[Music]
hey man just put the knife down it's
okay not the end of the world
we don't want to hurt you dude it's not
that big of a deal
just
it's
put
the
a black knife with about a six inch
blade
hey man it's okay
[Music]
what can i do to get you to put the
knife down brother
plate's gonna be
hey i'm
what's your name
what's your name my friend
hey hey dude it's just a car accident
it's not the end of the world there's no
reason to uh yeah
is your name
64 copy hey
i'm
okay
the driver is going to be
okay
we don't want to hurt you man i want to
put this gun down but i need you to put
that with that knife away
we don't want to hurt you dude
the last thing i want to do is hurt you
okay can you put the knife down
please
we're really here trying to help you out
okay
what's up it's deputy man
[Music]
hey dude so
we're none of us want to hurt you man
but you got a knife in your hand and
it's just a car accident dude it's not a
big deal
[Music]
hey i've been there dude i've messed up
before it's not that big of a deal but
what's gonna end up happening is
you know you got a knife and we don't
want to hurt you dude and that's really
going to be a big deal
[Music]
we just want to get you out of the car
and hey man and that's it we don't want
to hurt you we just want to talk to you
man but we can't do that if you have a
knife in your hand
[Music]
well
you know i you know what i've messed up
too in my life okay i really i have two
and i can tell you right now people
screw up but it's not the end of the
world
we you know we get second chances and
what i would hate to see is you get hurt
over this it's it's not that big of a
deal okay
you hit a car you hit a mailbox it's
it's not that big of a deal
we just want to get you out and we go
from there but
if you if you have that knife in your
hand you know
unfortunately we could end up hurting
you and that's not what we want to do
[Music]
okay can you drop the knife please
[Music]
okay you're scaring us with that knife
in your hand man okay none of us want to
hurt you like we said
and
there's better ways to resolve this than
than you know um
anyone hurting each other okay
it's just a car accident
i know
but it's uh
[Music]
yeah
and like i said obviously
yeah i don't know what you're going
through man i'm not going to pretend
like i know what you're going through
but i do want to help you dude okay
[Music]
thank you for not pretending
[Music]
to be like i know what you're going
through
yeah man we all go through different
things and
ultimately we're just here to get this
resolved safely dude okay
i'd love to hear you know what's going
on in your life but we need you to put
that knife down
i'd love to tell you what's going on
but we just don't have time for that
i'm sorry sir
okay
we got all the time in the world brother
all right
we really do there's no rush here okay
we just uh what can i do to get you to
put that knife down man
[Music]
is there anything i can do to you know
to help you out here
[Music]
this is a slap on the wrist
yeah but uh
you know at this point it's it's over
it's not brother i'm telling you man i
really am
and
especially at 23 bro
we this is not over
you have a lot to look forward to
and i'm being honest dude you you can
you you'll be able to go to that concert
it's a
it's a ticket bro it's uh considered a
misdemeanor not a big deal
come out with your ass up
you follow our commands and you'll be
okay
knife in his right hand
nice and right hand
drop the knife and come out with your
hands up
[Music]
come out with your hands up
hands up
check out the knife you still got the
knife
come out with your hands up
hands up
check out the bag
come out with your hands up
come on with your hands up
ass up
i got him right here
this knife out get this knife out
i got one
you guys need a knife hack i got one
you guys